hello and welcome to this free webinar
on metagenomics this introductory
webinar will
highlight applications of metagenomic
sequencing
and methods of analysis for metagenomic
data that are used
in various research biomedical and
agricultural applications
before we start speaking about
metagenomics
i wanted to introduce you to omics logic
programs
in africa and more specifically a new
partnership
with helix biogen institute that will
help more students and researchers gain
access to omix logic training
and research solutions in nigeria
to speak about the significance of data
literacy
and bioinformatics in nigeria i would
like to invite dr
oladipo elijah the founder of
helix
university dr has a phd in microbiology
and a master's degree in medical
microbiology
and parasitology in the past he has been
a lecturer and research director of
molecular biology
immunology and bioinformatics research
laboratory
and now continue to participate in
biochemistry
across nigeria and around the world dr
kolavule
over to you
yeah good afternoon everyone uh it's a
nice
privilege given to ross to be here and
to collaborate
with our partners uh pine biotech
t platformer turbo informatics uh alex
bergen institute
is a an upcoming
institute in nigeria that is
involved in capacity development in the
era of bioinformatics
and we have been running a lot of
courses like a certificate diploma
and now we are having a collaboration
with our partners now
in order to allow nigerian scientists
both young and old african scientists
both young and old
to know much about bioinformatics
and how to use various tools in order to
solve real life
problem and i want to believe that as we
are commencing
this program we know each other better
and
i wanted to know that that facilitators
for this program their hair health
to give you the best give you what it
takes to know
much about bioinformatics and as i
believe
that at the end of the seminar we all
will be interested to move further to
the next stage into the retraining
and thanks everyone we are welcome
thank you so much dr for organizing this
workshop
i would now like to see a few words
about the omics logic team and our
collaborators who have made this
training possible
my name is vip shabba
my name is beepsha bhaswas and i am the
omix logic community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users
that are part of our bioinformatics
community
managed by pine biotech over the course
of the past
several years our team has been
collaborating
with a number of academic institutions
around the world
that have participated in content
evaluation
curriculum review and project design as
a result
the omics logic programs have been
thoroughly evaluated
and are known to lead to excellent
outcomes
the goal of the omics logic programs is
to provide training
in bioinformatics enabling independent
research guided by mentors
and pure example developing a growing
community with
shared passion for data-driven research
and appreciation of citizen science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds to develop
novel and independent research using
latest technology
in life and data sciences
our mix logic metagenomics training
program will be guided by
experienced trainers that have ample
experience with bite for matrix
in both academic and industry
applications
i will now invite elya brodsky who is
the ceo
of pine biotic to speak about
metagenomic sequencing and the upcoming
program
over to you elia
thank you beeps and uh thank you
everyone for joining today's webinar
so what we are going to cover in this
webinar
is a little bit of an introduction to
metagenomics
sequencing and how this data could be
analyzed and used so that in the context
of the upcoming program
you will have a sense of what we will do
together
so let's start from the very beginning
the connection between disease and
microorganisms has been established
in the 1800s and already towards the end
of the 19th century
laboratory methods for growing
microorganisms in a lab
culture were developed helping
characterize them with staining
these studies provided important
information about bacterial
function in isolation but it was
soon apparent that most microorganisms
actually live in complex communities and
today we know
that the microorganisms or the
microbiota
communities of microorganisms that make
up the human microbiome
are not just unicellular organisms
living alongside each other but instead
they
form highly regulated structurally and
functionally organized communities
that are attached to surfaces as
biofilms
with interspecies collaboration and
antagonisms that contribute to ecologic
stability
now many of us are probably familiar
with this stability
it's fascinating that we know for
example trying to battle with such
common
skin conditions as eczema acne and dry
skin so these communities
are distinct and connected and they are
determined to maintain their community
the way that it is
and bacteria within a biofilm can
communicate with each other by producing
detecting and responding to small
diffusible signal molecules in a process
called quorum sensing
sensing which confirms benefit for host
colonization
biofilm formation defense against
competitors and adaptation to changes in
the environment
quorum sensing activities in biofilms
are also
involved in the virulence and pathogenic
potential of bacteria
and are therefore an important factor in
understanding and controlling bacterial
infections as they enable
microorganisms and biofilms to become
more tolerant of host defenses
and antimicrobial agents
so microorganisms are living in
communities
forming specific structures
and those structures help them maintain
that community
by leveraging different characteristics
of the bacterial species
found in a given microbiota or community
of
bacteria the human microbiota is
estimated to be
10 to the 13th to 10 to the 14th of
microbial cells so it was previously
thought
that there are many more microorganisms
in the human body
compared to the human cells but today we
know that approximately it's one to one
ratio of microbial cells to human cells
and these numbers are primarily derived
from the total bacterial cells in the
colon
which is the organ that harbors the
densest number of microbes
however each one of these microorganisms
carries
important functional properties and
genes that contain genomic information
these properties and the genomic
information about microorganisms
have been of a growing interest to the
scientific community
and so now there are over 80 000
publications on the
microbiome and this number is
continuously growing
showing the significance of microbiome
in a number of different applications
however the majority of biomedical
studies on the microbiome have until now
been about the gut microbiota but we'll
see
how major projects and ongoing studies
are expanding the role of microbiome
in a variety of different applications
so
since the 1990s microbiome studies have
significantly advanced our understanding
of different types of microbiota for
example we see here metagenomics of the
human
intestinal tract and the subsequent
human microbiome project these are
huge studies that have been made
possible through the advances in
metagenomic sequencing
as a result we now know that there is a
distinct skin
lung gut and even brain microbiota
that are characterized in the context of
healthy
but also diseased conditions
and so over the past decade more than
1.7 billion
us dollars has been invested in human
microbiome research
major projects are underway in the
united states
the european union china
canada ireland south korea and japan
and this investment has really showed
and confirmed the importance of the
microbiome
to human health and human development
some 20 of us investment in this
research
has gone to two phases of a large
project called the human
microbiome project or hmp which is
creating the research resources needed
to study
the human microbiome both in healthy
development
and in diseases and one of the major
goals of hmp
which was launched in 2007 was to create
a toolbox of reference data sets
computational techniques analytical
methods
and clinical protocols so let's talk a
little bit about
what is known about the microbiome
function
in for humans for people so today we
know
that endogenous human microbial
communities contribute to
a critical metabolic physiological
and immunological function including
differentiation
and maturation of the host mucosa and
its immune system
food digestion and nutrition energy
generation metabolic regulation and
control of fat
storage processing and detoxification of
environmental chemicals
maintenance of skin and mucosa barrier
function
development and regulation of the immune
system and prevention of invasion
and growth of disease-promoting
microorganisms
so to study these functions and how they
vary in different conditions there have
been a number of technologies
that have been instrumental to our
understanding of how
these communities live function and
develop
and respond to different stresses so
these questions are primarily being
answered by
two types of technologies one is called
sequencing so
whole genome sequencing or whole dna
sequencing
or metagenomic sequencing or meta
transcriptomic
sequencing as well as different types of
amplicon sequencing which we'll talk
about in just a
few more slides and mass spectrometry so
mass spectrometry allows us to detect
spectra of proteins and metabolites
and really understand what type of
functional
enzymes and molecules are being produced
by these microbiota
so here we'll talk about how these
techniques are used
and try to understand one of the major
functions of metagenomic sequencing
which really
allows us to understand the
communities as a functional
group and so we'll talk a little bit
about how
the microbiota could be sequenced
mapped onto a database of reference
genomes of all known bacterial genomes
and give us a sense of species richness
so in this context metagenomics is
really
different from other types of omics data
so typically when you think about omics
data you're thinking about genomics or
transcriptomics and all of these focus
on the whole of a single organism
and organisms like metagenomics
is the community of microorganisms
they live in communities and so when we
think of metagenomic sequencing we're
really trying to understand
the composition and the structure of
that community
and so this genetic material is sampled
directly from an
environment so it skips that stage of
isolating a particular strain
and allows us to understand how do they
interact with each other
in their natural environment and so
when we think of metagenomics
we can really think of them in two ways
so
the first one could be applied to
environmental
culture free sequencing to study
populations
and we can also use sequencing to
extract
a particular strain and understand
how it relates to other types of known
genomes that we have characterized so
these two types are really sometimes
used in a complementary way
for example if we want to look at the
gut microbiome we want to ask the
question
what types of bacteria and in what
proportions are they
inside this particular individual
and we might want to compare that
individual to another individual
and sometimes we want to understand how
a particular
member of this community behaves and
what's different about it
for example a uh some kind of a
antibiotic resistant bacteria or
microorganism
and then we can use full genome assembly
and mapping to understand how it could
be
mapped to known species so
the first type which is really 16s
ribosomal rna metagenomic sequencing
is a low cost and flexible approach
to study how the composition
of a particular microbiota could be
characterized
so this kind of a sequencing allows us
to
essentially extract a 1500
long base pair
sequence of the 16s ribosomal rna gene
map it onto a database where we have
organized all of our data into
operational taxonomic units through
pairwise
uh peer-ended sequencing and by mapping
we are really understanding how
a taxonomy of a particular microbiota
explains a particular microbiota a
particular defined
community so what is the 16
s ribosomal rna gene you have
the bottom ribosomal subunit or the 30s
small subunit of the ribosome that is
specific to
bacteria inside that you have the 16s
ribosomal rna gene so this is actually
rna
and that could be sequenced using a
specific
primer so that you're only sequencing
four particular hypervariable regions
now a lot of times
hypervariable regions 3 and 4 are used
and by mapping those onto a known
sequence of 16s ribosomal rna
we have a particular sensitivity
to different levels of taxonomic
classification so we can ask the
question
for example what you see here is based
on phyla
of all species that are present what is
the proportion of different phyla
in different places of the body for
example you can see here skin
oral cavity etc and now you can ask the
question
well how can we analyze this data
and what are some of the approaches to
ask specific research
questions of the data that we have
generated using next generation
sequencing
so an important part of this is to
really
understand the relationship
between different microbiota and the
relationship between
the host and whatever that community
contains
which could contain a number of members
for example
bacteria and viruses right so those
could be pathogens and they could be
helpful bacteria and so we want to for
example know the composition
how much how many are viruses how many
are
bacteria or what types of viruses are
present or what types of bacteria are
present
we might want to understand the
relationship between the host
and the microbiota for example changes
in microbiota
how do they affect the host or if we
have specific clinical or phenotypic
data
for example disease stage and not
disease stage susceptible and not
susceptible
how do we characterize those types of
interactions
and changes across different conditions
so
ultimately the role of bioinformatics
and different
aspects of bioinformatics is to help
establish
those relationships and help us identify
specific types of relationships that
could be applied to
the development of biomarkers and an
understanding
of specificity features and
result of changes in those features as
we think about
diagnostic and therapeutic applications
so let's take a look at a few examples
and by the way
all of these examples are taken so that
we can understand and anticipate
what kind of training is going to happen
when we turn to the metagenomic
onyx logic metagenomic program so
what are project examples when we say
project
examples really what we mean is curated
data sets
digested publications and guided
tutorials
that we're going to include in the onyx
logic metagenomics training program
so that any one of you without or with
some background in bioinformatics and in
microbiology
can understand how this metagenomic
sequencing data could be
analyzed for some kind of a valuable
application
so what are those valuable applications
one example is a project called the
american gut
and even though it's called the american
gut this is a part of the human
microbiome project so
in fact international participants have
contributed
their samples to a group that
studies those samples by sequencing them
and
asking survey data to establish some
general trends
about the way that the people that are
reporting for example sensitivities or
their level of activity
or their background ethnic background
and their
location or maybe a specific food diet
we can understand
variation of healthy human microbiome so
one of the examples that we'll do is
we'll take
a number of representatives from the
american
microbiome project and we're going to
prepare a report so this
is what you see right here this is an
actual report from the american
gut that shows how a particular
user that has submitted their samples
what
are the most abundant microbes most
enriched microbes
how does your microbiome compare to
others
and maybe some specific examples of
different groups people that are more
active and less active and so we'll ask
the question what are some general
trends
for microbiome variation in healthy
human population another important
application of microbiome is
something that is a little bit less
intuitive so we'll take a look at a
project
that tries to separate the influence of
microbiome changes
from the overall environmental
conditions
that have in association with
different types of behavior so we'll
take a look at an animal
model study where animals were fed
with a particular diet a high fat diet
versus a normal diet
and then that microbiome once it has
been established
was transplanted into another set of
animals
and then their behavior was studied and
so
through those kinds of studies we'll see
how you can observe
a relationship between microbiome
composition
presence of particular bacterial phyla
or species
and the composition of it and then you
can identify
potentially an interesting insight into
how
anxiety and behavior could be affected
simply by microbiome another
important application of microbiome that
we'll look at
is the determine the the way that the
microbiome
and the food that the microbiome thrives
on
determines efficacy of treatment
and our response to
different types of triggers
psychological triggers behavioral
triggers
etc so we'll see at the way that
these types of data sets could really be
informative
and lead to development of intervention
so we'll in fact look at one example
where
a treatment using microbiome
from fecal samples was approved in china
for alzheimer's disease so really
interesting applications of microbiome
in terms of treatment
but we'll also look at the impact of the
microbiome
on treatment response so how
microbiome composition of individual
patients
can have an effect on their toxicity
and beneficial treatment metabolism so
we'll
look at microbiome as an important layer
in that process of taking a treatment
taking a drug
and essentially what happens how
effective is that treatment
is also determined by the microbiome
which is logical right because we just
saw how the microbiome
is related to the immune system and it
forms a biofilm essentially
on the layers of our body that are
exposed to these treatments
but of course microbiome is not only
useful
in biomedical applications it also has a
huge benefit for agriculture and so
we'll see
how microbial communities from the soil
from the water have a major impact
on the growth and the productivity
of particular types of crops
and for example we look at microbial
fertilizers
which are an emerging class of organic
fertilizers
and consist of dried microbial biomass
for instance produced
on effluents from the food and beverage
industry
so they have been shown to provide
unique benefits
especially in harsh conditions and at
the same time with minimal environmental
impacts and metagenomic studies on
agricultural applications of microbiome
are really showing
promise in terms of our understanding of
the role of microbiome
but also our ability to develop novel
applications that are designed
to make the crops more productive and
more resilient
in harsher conditions that are coming as
a result of climate change
so now to explain how all of these
topics are going to be covered in our
upcoming program
i will pass it on to dr mohit mazumdar
who is going to explain
what the program consists of and how to
register
thank you and hello everyone
so let me share my screen
so ilya can you make me co-host i have
another login
dr mohit majumdar
yes sorry yeah
thanks
okay hello everyone and my name is mohit
mazumdar
and i'm one of the global
representatives of pinewire tech and in
my current role i'm working with
scientists to search as students to
assess
with their big data research so talking
about today's uh
session and this program itself so omix
logic metagenomics is a specialized
program
that not only takes you through the live
sessions courses
and example projects but also get you to
learn by
applying this knowledge to a real
metagenomics project
so as in our all
as in in all of our omics logic training
programs
we will leverage online interactive
sessions
self-guided study materials and
that are crafted uh designed for with
practical examples so we'll go through
practical assignments
for an immersive experience that has
proven to be effective for thousands of
students who have already completed our
omics logic
training programs so this
uh online program is basically designed
to be
equally rewarding for students and
researchers
and especially suited for project based
learning
on a flexible schedule so this program
will
cover uh main aspects of metagenomic
sequencing
analysis of 16s rrna
and other aspects of microbiology
research using bioinformatics
so 16s metagenomics data processing
would
result in a table of annotated 16s rrna
genes
and they will be read map counts so the
table
includes annotation that that would have
like levels of
kingdom phylum class order family genus
and species and things like that
so we will be covering those at uh
towards the beginning
where we will be doing the first session
uh covering introduction to metagenomics
on 16 february
and then uh mapping to uh different
databases
so how we can do the annotation and com
uh and find uh those using different
databases that are available
then as india discussed that we will be
going through the
uh data to pipeline and there we will be
using
other tools such as filo seek and then
the projects so after going through the
couple of the introductory session and
understanding
how to apply metagenomic sequencing into
uh research or understanding by project
examples
we will be going through uh the gut
microbiota
biome project human microbiome to
understand the human microbiome
variability and followed by that we will
have another project session
on uh on the gut mic gut brain access
and then we will be learning about uh
the independent project so the
process and towards the end
of this program participants will be
conducting
independent or group projects analyzing
data from
public domain and learning from high
impact biomedical publications on
microbiome
so in order to study microbiome or
microbial communities or microbiome
microbiomes we will be learning about a
couple of technologies like
we discussed like we will be learning
about 16s and 18s ribosomal rnas
and the way analysis to analyze the
hyper variable
regions that can yield important
information
about the microbial microbiome
composition
so uh the sessions will include
asynchronous materials which which have
all the information like uh the things
that we have discussed
they are well described in the courses
so good understanding of the way data is
being prepared we will understand
through the courses and the
asynchronous projects and how this data
is
helping us allowing us to navigate
research
studies with ease that we will be
learning through
the asynchronous courses and that will
be showcasing you
in a while that uh these introductory
and
hands-on courses along with the
educational project that you will have
access to
throughout this time so other than the
online sessions
throughout the week we will be going
through
courses and online projects
so this will be done via the zoom
session so
as this session is ongoing right now we
will have zoom sessions throughout
this entire program starting from 16
february
and the sessions will be held at the
same time 5 p.m to 6 30 p.m
western africa time and uh we will have
a team of supporters to be
able to help you transition this
knowledge from
theoretical knowledge to practical
assignments to applying this
uh applying this into a research project
so this entire process will be guided by
us
and also will be help getting help from
our africa
from our nigerian team which we will be
whom we will be introducing in a while
so uh during this uh during the last
program or also this uh
during this program once we transition
so first
the first part would be to learn from
the theoretical aspects and learn about
the basics
and then go through the practical
assignments and go through the data sets
and learn how to apply them and then
during the
end of the program towards the end of
the program we would ask you to submit a
research proposal so that research
proposal
that would have a unique idea or an idea
that you wanted to work on
and that you have discussed with the
mentor and have
uh and that you are sure about the
analysis process
and identified the data set and also the
pros uh the analysis
uh methodology that you will be taking
so we will be
uh peer reviewing that uh proposal
further
with our experts the uh whom we have
collaborated in the university
and also tower bioinformatics research
center to
be get to be able to get uh uh
peer-reviewed feedback so that we can
improve our research
and move in the right direction so this
whole week towards the end will
include uh one-on-one meetings with the
mentor to to work on the proposal
and also we'll have group presentations
where uh
where the participants will get a cha
will get a chance
to talk about what they have learned and
what they understand
from the point of from their point of
view about the
research question and the analysis that
they wanted to do
so we have been doing it for a while so
our omics logic
metagenomics program has been taken by
hundreds of researchers that includes
researchers who starts from the very
basic without
any background of bioinformatics and
also
uh researchers who come from a
background
who understands and knows how to how to
apply these technology
to a research question so there are
different expectations that
we have uh we have seen from different
uh categories of students
who starting who are starting from the
beginning uh students who are doing
their phd
research and would want to uh do
something that would help them publish
or for faculties who are working on some
research projects
that they want to publish or they want
to apply
for more funding so we have been working
with
these researchers and we have been
helping them through our omics logic
research programs
so some of the examples like during the
last program that resulted in like
multiple numerous independent research
project proposals
so the project proposals were then
pre-reviewed as i was telling you
and some of them include the analysis of
microbial
ecology of the international space
station
and then implications of long-term human
missions on moon and moon and mars so
thinking about how metagenomics analysis
and how we
these samples that we're collecting
giving us information
to get a better living or to improve
uh what we the challenges that we are
facing by understanding the environment
around by understanding the microbiota
so i'm really excited to be a part of
this collaborative research program
and meeting you all here today and i'm
looking forward to meeting the parties
to meet the participants who decides to
join the program and to talk
more about the program and the
registration part
let me invite people to guide you
through that process
but i'll i'm i'm here i'm available to
you
and you can always reach out to us for
any kind of questions
regarding research or projects that you
have interest in
in this area in this field of
metagenomics
thank you thank you so much
dr mohit
now i would like to draw your attention
to the program
resources for different parts of the
session we will leverage
omix logic resources that you can use to
learn about metagenomics
these will include asynchronous
coursework with theoretical material
quizzes practical assignments our
cloud-based
analytical server where you can analyze
large metagenomic data and visualize
results
the omits logic code playground where
you can practice coding
in r and python as well as a repository
of
project examples we will start with
introductory course work in metagenomics
where we will familiarize ourselves with
the world
of the microbiome the modules will also
explain
key terminology and some of the project
data sets we will use
in the analysis some of the practical
analysis
approaches we will cover in this program
includes
kind to data to pipelines and phyloseek
throughout the course you will be given
directions to access the
bioinfo platform for bioinformatics
processing
and analysis of metagenomic data
the platform includes demo pipelines
as well as data management and analysis
cloud infrastructure
to run bioinformatics pipelines
different stages of analysis are
performed
in this different section of this
multi-omics platform
the visual interface of the tbio info
platform will
enable users to quickly build logical
crafts like you're seeing on the screen
of their analysis
and understand each step significant in
running the pipeline
for those interested to implement the
pipeline
on their own we will also offer guidance
and references that can be used
to effectively install all the required
packages for the pipeline
behind many of the scripts written in
popular coding languages such as
r and python these are also explained in
tutorials you will have access to on our
code omits logic platform
these include beginner tutorials on data
importing
preparation for analysis and standard
visualization
of process data more specialized
packages with publication ready outputs
will be covered in more advanced lessons
that is why this program is built to
provide students of
all backgrounds with a clear perspective
on big data analytics
machine learning and artificial
intelligence
our omics logic step-by-step process is
enabled by
access to complex tools via a simple
and intuitive analysis
platform at the same time exposing
participants
to analysis logic in the context of real
data sets
as you have seen dr mohit explain
an extrapolation of this logic to a
variety of
projects and data sets with assistance
from
mentor and technical support
the first step therefore is to register
yourself
and start updating your profile like you
see the participants
doing here here
are also a few examples from previous
participants
who have taken part in the omics logic
programs
reviewed these programs
and also proposed novel research
projects
we are excited that this event has been
led
and organized by a dedicated team in
nigeria that brings together experts who
have an
interest in data driven research and
have all recently completed
our specialized training they are now
certified and ready to assist
all of you in joining the program
getting registered finding
all the necessary resources and helping
you troubleshoot any technical or
conceptual challenges you come across
we have adequately adeloboy who is our
omits logic project lead
and a faculty at leap city university in
nigeria
adidas is the omits logic community
manager for
africa and he is a faculty at the
department of oral diagnostic sciences
at bairo sani hamza
is a medical laboratory scientist at the
university of
lagos in nigeria i would now like to
invite
adi kundi to say a few words about the
programs that we are running in nigeria
and his experience
adi kunde over to you
thank you very much thank you sir um
i'm very excited to be here this evening
um speaking with us
i'm a faculty with lead city university
here in nigeria
and
across the globe particularly here in
africa um
and nigeria in order to gather relevant
bioinformatics efforts
and that is relevant to meta dynamics um
you know with particular focus on
hands-on experience you know that would
help participants
to benefit in laws and be able to apply
this to their own personal proof
you know i'm glad to see that the
feedback we've had
you know from previous programs will be
running
including some which are currently
ongoing has always been an exciting
you know it is us in the in the team
here in nigeria
and a lot of joy to see that but you
can't get value for
for the money they pay for such programs
as this
and um you know um one of our goal of
course is to see participants
you know literally after the time of
beginning trainings like this
you know to bring people to learn
relevance keys and applying
same skills to their own personalities
okay so with that
convention of course i have no doubt
that for as many
needed support and mentorship as well as
support that is necessary for
participants to get the very best
from these and forthcoming data genomics
and program
and so i would want to pass it on to my
you know our community manager here in
nigeria
and just i decided to equally have and
one or two
i mean to see one or two things thank
you
hello good evening everybody thank you
for
coming here today my name is anita
abushary
i'm a consultant or pathologist at the
american teaching hospital
in canada i'm also a lecturer at
bayern university canada and i'm the
community manager
for omis logics nigeria
i'm also from pibal tech usa we are very
glad to have you with us
and we are also very glad to partner
this with
dr elijah
this this new metagenomics course
we promise that all your questions
queries
shall be duly answered
and whatever queries or questions you
have you can do listening to african
about you'll get prompt response prompt
registration
um on prompt answers to all your queries
thank you and we wish you join us to
make this community more formidable
and to be avant-garde in metal genomics
in
nigeria in africa as a whole thank you
very much i'll pass the banana to
dipster
hello bipsaw thank you so much adikulian
aditayo
for sharing
i would now like to invite everyone to
get started by registering yourself on
edut bio info this is the first
platform that we will all utilize for
the program
so there is a free registration if you
click on the register button once you
are edu dot t bio info at the time if
you can kindly share
the url in the chat box
and if you are already logged in i will
be showing you the next steps on how you
can register so please go with me to
edu.t
bioinfo and if you have not yet
registered for the program or joining us
for the first time
we'll have the register button right
here and there will be a pop-up where
you can
enter your email id and set your
password
and you can log in to the website thank
you so much aditayo for sharing
so let us go and see how this program
is going to be conducted so
this is what we call the organization
page
for the metagenomics program
in collaboration with helix virgin
institute
in this page i am posting the link
to this page so if you are already
logged in
you will be able to have an overview of
the page
though you will not be able to access
the full page
here you will find the events the
upcoming events of the program so as dr
mohit has already explained to you we
are starting on the 16th of february
so you have about two weeks to join this
program
now talking about the registration
process this is the direct
link to register for the program if you
are
already logged in to the portal you will
be able to access this direct link
and you can see here the details of the
program
now the cost of the program is 150
dollars
but we are giving a special discount for
our participants who are joining us
and to avail that 50 percent discount
we will be safe sending everyone an
email
with a quote and that will make the 150
200 which will give you a 50 percent
discount
and in case there are students who are
not able to afford
the 100 program we also have
a scholarship option which we will again
share via email
and let me explain the scholarship
option to you
the way the scholarship works whenever
we have the scholarship option we ask
the students to
go ahead and meet with us along with one
of their references
so if you're applying for the
scholarship program
you will have to mention the name of
three of your references
and to reach out to them so that they
can join us
for a meeting based on that meeting
where we can
talk to your uh reference
as well as you and learn more about
where you're coming from and how much
time you can dedicate to this
program you would be offered that
scholarship
so if you are wanting to join this
program and have an
interest in metagenomic research then
please start applying for the program as
soon as you receive that
email from us
and moving on i would now like to open
the chat for
any questions that you may have and
invite you all to join the program
and as i did note in the chat there are
a lot of participants today
who are also interested in infectious
disease
research so i would also like to draw
your
attention to another program that we are
all having
on bi-informatics for infectious disease
research
as part of in collaboration with noguchi
memorial
research institute in ghana so if you
are a researcher
or a student interested in infectious
diseases
you can also check out this program
which we are
starting from tomorrow
and i'm posting the link again in the
chat box you will receive all of these
details
and all of you who have shared all of
these details with us
we will reach out to you personally via
email
so please make sure that you have also
added your email ids in the chat box so
that we can reach out to you personally
and now i want to open this for any
questions
that you may have
and as you are asking all of these
questions
i would also want to invite you all to
go ahead and join
our social media groups
okay thank you for uh sharing your
details here
i wanted to mention that one of the
reasons why
vipsa asked all of you to complete the
free registration
on the educational portal is so that you
can gain already access to the free
course called introduction to
metagenomics
this free course is going to introduce
you to the basic
concepts terminology and applications
just like what we did today
in this session but in a more expanded
way
and we hope that by joining that course
you will be able to have
access to our additional free resources
that might be relevant to you
so i would like to make sure that
uh all of you have tried that and if you
come across
any issues you're welcome to uh email us
at uh vipsa or marketing at pine dot bio
or africa at pine at bio specifically if
you are in
nigeria or in africa in general and
also we mentioned uh these social media
groups and the reason why we ask you to
join the social media groups is because
we see
this uh program that we're going to be
doing with helix
biogen institute as a one of the steps
in building a community
of those of you that are interested in
bioinformatics to application
in application to biomedical and
agricultural biotechnology
challenges so we hope to stay in touch
with you long term
and really get to know all of you as
well as the institutions that are
represented here
and uh you know develop a sense
of what are the most practical solutions
and training that is needed
for all of you that are participating in
these free webinars
thank you uh thank you elio
and thank you everyone for joining us
today
we look forward to having you with us in
the upcoming session
please reach out to our team at
marketing and find out bio and
africa find out bio for any questions
related to this upcoming program
and all of you who have shared your
email ids in the chat box we will be
reaching out to you
and if you have mentioned any specific
interests we will also be
reaching out to you regarding all the
resources that we have
is referred to that specific interest so
thank you again today
if you do not have any more questions we
would like to
end today's session
you